he is a radio network analyst of the
Washington Redskins and one of our
favorite guests in our podcast history
that the show is up and borne out of
he's none other than Chris Cooley how
are you Christopher Rich Eisen what's up
my man I am better for talking to you
you still pranking people no you're out
of that game but I just got off the
phone with someone who you know I think
you know the person I won't I won't I'll
leave him unnamed but why I said get
back in get back into what get back into
the prank-call game he may or may not
work you know around you so it could be
it could be all rich as time here coming
up in the next couple now we need a
little bit more meat on the bones here
so just got off the phone with somebody
who wants to prank call me is that what
you're saying no no I'm gonna play call
you I told you though I know you want
because you got me kind of got me last
time oh my son broke up a little bit you
tried it you try to get me one time
where you you did two things first of
all you have the flu you have the worst
fake voice of all time when you try to
fake fake your voice that's number one
and then number two is you didn't block
your number I have your number you know
what I mean like you're in my phone so
shows up chris cooley that's what it
showed up yeah that's fine I mean it was
really all in good fun
that's all it man you some other some
other radio show hosts to call me and
offer me some fake job mmm okay well
we're gonna we're gonna work on all of
that stuff Christopher so okay you know
that right he's let's you typing oh I
thought it was Utah State might be right
really you better be careful on that one
oh my god it Steve sees a University of
Utah I thought it was your toaster yeah
University of Utah I'm glad I got my
mistake out of the way here on this show
instead of in front of Steve Smith
because that you know anything's
fighting words to him sometimes you'll
take it that way so Chris what what what
would you say is the Redskins 2017
season walk me through what you would
consider this season to be so far at
five and six this is a really good
football team that's battled so many
injuries rich they they have been
decimated throughout the entire season
you start on offense
we played a game in Seattle that they
actually won a month ago
with only Shawn Laval healthy on my
offensive line we had four of our
starters out for the game
you had six players out on defense for
that game our first-round pick Jonathan
Allen has been out Jordan Reed's been
out a lot of the year trial prior that
really had a great year is now out for
the year and you run down list it's
incredible the team that started the
season a team that's here but here's
what I see and this is in all honesty
and I you know I'm a homer I knew that
but this is very true
this is this is no made-up they want to
win for each other and they play for Jay
Gruden and they play hard there's
something to this team and I mean even
if they win five they might not be a
playoff team but I actually like this
team so I think it's really cool I think
they're a tough team
I think they've gotten better Kirk's
gotten better everyone's improving it's
been a tough day but I do like the team
so Jay Gruden is not coaching for his
job that's what you're saying
I don't think though no okay because the
team the front office knows that they
play for him hard guard listen what's
going on all right so not good I figured
okay does the front office like their
quarterback what do you think I think I
think that they've underestimated their
quarterback and I know that sounds crazy
but I really do think they've
underestimated their quarterback from
two years ago in contract negotiations
all the way through this year when they
put out the statement trying to make him
the highest-paid player and I look at it
and people really that's kind of not the
case I don't believe there was a report
from the inter a port last week that
said the team is evaluating Kirk over
the last five games mm-hmm I don't
believe I know that didn't come from our
team president Varela
I don't know if it did come from someone
in the organization I don't you never
really want to question that I know it
didn't come from razón and so I also
know that they're not really evaluating
the last five game because they know who
he is
well I mean but they like side also so
here's the deal sorry I'm glad you I
know it's a trophy
where's no no go for Jay hasn't paid a
quarterback bruises and paid a
quarterback Dan hasn't paid a
quarterback Eric Schaeffer because
they're contractors never really paid a
quarterback so I think they're under
estimating the gravity of what the
quarterback position is going to be paid
well I mean they're paying him some of
the most out there and they're I mean
the amount of money that Kirk has made
over the last two years if they decided
to sign him long term
two years ago they could have been
paying him less guaranteed but I mean
that that horse has already left the
barn who chris cooley here on the Rich
Eisen show who is Kirk Cousins and that
that's this let me let me finish the
setup to the question this way the guy
who made two incredible throws in
Seattle to win that game and pull it out
right
the guy who lit up in in the in the
Superdome to go up 15 on Drew Brees and
that wasn't his fault that he handed it
off three times in the one lone
possession in between the two Drew Brees
touchdowns he did get them in a position
to win that game or is he the guy that
couldn't finish against Philadelphia in
week one or the guy who couldn't who
barely beat a Giants team and who knew
at the time was moving on from from from
Eli who is Kirk then Chris he was so
this year Kirk a I think it's been his
best year I think he's grown
I think he's played with with really a
lack of a group around him as opposed to
what he's had in the past he's
consistently battled through his other
guys getting hurt make plays he's he's
got a new play caller in Jagran and it's
the same verbage offensively here's
where he's really grown he's grown in
the areas that he last over the last
couple years more than I've more than
I've really expected he's making off
schedule plays he's scrambling
he's finding the deep throw down the
field more times than not which i think
is actually really important but last
year for example his yards per attempt
were down field were most in the league
and he threw the ball per completion
more downfield than any quarterback in
the league so can be somewhat skewed
statistically but this year truly rich
he's not missing things downfield now
watch it close I watched every game on
film like all your guys doesn't miss
much he's been he's been really
good and you had more sacks that's one
negative but he's had so many linemen
hurt last week yet
Trent Williams out and he had Sean
Lavelle out we had our third Center Toni
Bergstrom who who came into this team
three weeks ago and for the game so more
sacks but different offensive line less
weapons better production and so what
about tonight who's in there tonight
well what what Redskins team we're gonna
see in this build I think Aaron Williams
is gonna play tonight ain't Joanna's
gonna play tonight ain't same guys
Senator Tony Burton played tonight no
Jordan Reed well I mean that's just
what's going on with him he keeps
pulling his hamstring can't see healthy
but Verna Davey now and believe it
so Jordan had a toe deal at the
beginning of the year right right I
don't know if you knew that will anyone
listen any other toe deal we never
really got that much better and it
really bothered I talked to her
yesterday and it's really bothering him
and it's making it the way he runs and
moves overcompensate it's been a hard
year he's really frustrated Jordan is
not obviously anyone would be but Vernon
has really stepped up and doesn't
connect think ask him the poll question
before we send him into the Dallas day
to come into this building tonight Chris
yeah yeah Chris which five and six team
in the NFC is the best chance to make
the playoffs
Cowboys Redskins Cardinals Packers none
what do you think now knowing what you
got in front of you here you know that
the Redskins do have obviously an easier
schedule nobody above 500 currently
remaining on charger I don't win the AFC
West charges are good team no I'm
talking about the NFC right now what do
you think about that red can play the
Chargers next week they're not looking
for 500 oh good all right so I mean
Green Bay has a legit shot because they
could get Rogers back he's nocturnal
Chris yet passes a week ago and they
have a pretty easy couple weeks but they
also play Detroit which is gonna be
critical the thing for the Redskins that
stuff is even if they win five in a row
and get to ten and six tie break
scenarios making it pretty tough for
them to get in a lot can happen I do
believe they could win out but that I
think there's going to be a 10 and 16
rich that doesn't make it this year and
I front are you surprised how well Sean
McVeigh is doing
in Los Angeles aw huh I'm I'm not yes to
some extent that they're as good but I'm
not surprised that they're having
success I thought it did a great job
with hires I thought Wade Phillips was
was awesome they all were already very
talented on defense and so you know I
looked at this year for hunted and Sean
can just score twenty yeah I'm pretty
good year
just twenty a game and I'm you know Sean
twenty he came and I as good as they are
may be a little bit surprised but not
he's he's the best I've been around well
I mean but in terms of hey look I mean
you never know I mean if the Seahawks
keep winning and then the rams get
kicked into a wild-card race it's bad
boys scenario but the Redskins have
already have and when the Rams were
putting thirty on everybody in the first
six weeks of the season the only team
that held them the lesson that was
Washington in Los Angeles I know and the
Redskins ran the football 65 percent of
the time in that game huh and we'll see
Pierre on tonight Chris great chatting
with you as always let's hope to run
into you tonight you got it thanks for
calling Chris but early at the Coulee
Zone on Twitter so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience